as fake conservatives send leftists to
mock pro-lifers at CPAC environmentalist
congresswoman AOC guzzles fossil fuels
and Democrats double down on
anti-semitism and racial bigotry one
thing has become abundantly clear
President Trump is more principled than
his critics then we will discuss what a
documentary about Michael Jackson
molesting little kids can tell us about
our political culture a lot more to get
to I'm Michael nose this is the Michael
Nolt show
[Music]
the center holds at CPAC and it reveals
one of the shocking truths to a lot of
people on the right and the left all we
have heard on the right and the left is
Donald Trump he doesn't have any
principles maybe he's a good president
maybe he's doing good things you don't
have any principles though obviously the
never Trump crowd says this obviously
the whole left says this doesn't have
any principles it has become very clear
within the last few weeks
Donald Trump is far more principled than
his critics to the right or the left
we'll get to that in a second but first
let's make a little money honey with
purple mattress oh how I love purple
mattress purple you know I obviously I
need to get twenty hours of sleep at
night I was trying to go to sleep last
night
and I have these lunatics who live above
me who just scream at each other all
night long and I would have been awake
all night if not for my purple mattress
they're loud awful shouting was only
beaten out by the comfort of my
beautiful purple mattress I was very
skeptical about purple at first because
it's not an inner spring it's not a
memory foam exactly it's this new
material developed by rocket scientists
it's firm and soft at the same time how
is that possible
I didn't think it was possible it is it
is the greatest bet I've had in my life
I have been recommended it to a zillion
people I you know basically tossed my
old bed out the second I got it I
absolutely loved it hundred night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund backed by a 10-year
warranty free shipping and returns free
in-home setup an old mattress removal
you will love it right now my listeners
will get a free purple pillow with the
purchase of a mattress that is in
addition to the great free gifts they're
offering site-wide just text cough fa ce
o-- v fe fe 2 8 4 8 8 8 that's the only
way to get this free pillow text cough
if a right now co v fe fe 2 8 4 8 8 8 co
v fe fe 8 4 8 8 8 message and data rates
may apply the CPAC speech was so good
it was so great Donald Trump at the
Conservative Political Action Conference
I unfortunately wasn't able to get out
there this year I used to love going to
CPAC when I was younger we
just got stuck in la-la-land this year
couldn't make it happen I loved watching
it from afar Donald Trump went out there
a lot of you already saw clips from it
he talked for over two hours
largely ad-libbing largely improvising
the speech it the only thing I didn't
like about it is a couple times he he
went blue not he didn't go Democrat he
went blue with his language he used to
swear words in public which I just don't
like I'm look I'll talk like a sailor if
I'm at the bar with the hanging out with
the guys or something I don't like it
when my president does that I don't like
it broadly when people do that in public
there is a time in a place where
everything people should have
disciplined with their words if you're
not disciplined with your language then
you might not be disciplined in your
thinking or your behavior either that's
the one criticism I have of this speech
I don't like it when when people who
were in dignified positions use swear
words in public that said that's my only
criticism the speech was fabulous the
speech was unbelievably good he covered
everything he covered all of the ground
and I look you've probably seen him on
the in and I'm just gonna play one clip
from it where he went right to the heart
of the matter with Democrats went
brutally right some people said he went
over the edge he didn't he identified
the problem with the Democrat Party the
problem with the up-and-coming
fresh-faced Democrats and he said it in
no uncertain terms we have people in
Congress right now we have people in
Congress that hate our country
[Applause]
and you know that and we can name every
one of them if they want they hate our
country
[Applause]
sad it's very sad when I see some of the
things being made the statements being
made it's very very sad very and find
out how did they do in their country
just ask him how did they do did they do
well were they succeeding just ask that
question somebody would say oh that's
terrible that he brings it up but that's
ok I don't mind I'll bring it up how did
they do in their country not so good now
if you don't know what he is referring
to here he's referring to freshman
representative Ilan Umar he's referring
to this this woman she's an immigrant
and she doesn't like America
she doesn't like America she doesn't
like our allies and he makes a big
statement he said there are Democrats in
Congress who hate our country that is a
big statement you can't make that
statement unless you can back it up with
facts he did he's referring to Allah no
more Ilan Omar has defended nine men who
tried to join Isis from the United
States she defended them she asked for
leniency for them she's backing
terrorists she blamed the u.s. for a
terrorist attack on a Kenyan mall in
2013 she blames the United States when
terrorist attacks happen on the broader
topic so he defends it with that obvious
specific example say there are Democrats
who don't support our country who hate
our country this is true they protest
the American flag and they endorse
protests of the American flag you just
have to go that NFL protest from a
couple years ago they protest the flag
itself the symbol of the country itself
and Democrats are pleased to back them
up pleased to support them for it the
rest of the speech was like this you
know as I said he used a little salty
language in there it may be the case
that our culture is so degraded that you
sort of have to do this to win over a
crowd I've heard a lot of people tell me
they loved it
oh I loved when he used his real
language like the real people use maybe
that's true maybe he's onto something I
don't know I mean that's a sad thing for
the culture but I guess I can understand
it if that's where the culture is
broadly he goes on in this speech for
two hours it's very
hard to do that people don't appreciate
just as that a technical show business
aspect of his speeches how difficult it
is to do what he does so he's a little
loose with his language he kind of goes
here in the air he makes twists and
turns to speak for two hours is very
hard especially if you want to keep
people engaged and people were engaged
with every second of that so I watched
every second of that speech he is a
masterful communicator he is a masterful
showman he is a masterful politician now
those of us who've been paying attention
have known all that for a long time but
the one question that remained that I
still hear people say even supporters of
the president they say yeah but he don't
have any principles yeah he's good at
politics he's good at communicating but
I don't have any principles that isn't
true this weekend this CPAC showed that
Donald Trump is more principled than his
critics I'm speaking in particular I'll
go after his critics on the right for a
second then we can turn to the left
I have refrained from criticizing Bill
Kristol
I've largely refrained from it this is
because I like Bill Kristol he was a
teacher of mine for a summer in DC I
listened to his podcast sometimes
conversations with Bill Kristol which I
usually enjoy I have to bring it up
because Bill Kristol has made himself
the news story so we have to talk about
it he was the leading never Trump er he
was probably the main face of never
Trump and still is he started a website
called the bulwark with Charlie Sykes
and the the motto of the bulwark is
conservatism conserved the argument
being were the real conservatives and
and the Republican Party and Donald
Trump and people who support the
Republican president they're fake
conservatives we however are the real
conservatives and I entertained this
argument because well I thought it was a
wrong argument
I understood the logic of it the logic
basically was we're so conservative that
we live in this totally pure esoteric
ethereal realm that has
nothing to do with real politics we
would never soil our principles by
engaging in the reality of politics now
you might say that that is an
unprincipled position in itself which I
would say but I at least have got that
argument this weekend that argument fell
apart that nevertrump argument
completely dissolved because what the
bulwark did was they sent a leftist
reporter Molly John fast to report on
CPAC and they were promoting this all
where they'd say well you're gonna want
to pay attention to Molly John fasts
reports who you're gonna really like
this who he they were really promoting
this this wasn't some random freelancer
who went off-script this was they sent a
leftist him to Moxie Beck and what did
she do she filed a piece for the bulwark
called CPAC is definitely the bad place
in that piece you can read it yourself
she attacks pro-lifers she refers to
them as anti-choice almost exclusively
if not exclusively she attacks the
Reagan administration over its policy in
Latin America she taxed the NRA if you
attract ECTS second cement supporters
she attacks Charlie Kirk for being a
high school to her college high school
dropout a college dropout who then goes
in lecturers college students about free
speech on campus I believe I'm not sure
of this I believe Molly herself is a
college dropout so it's kind of weird
for her to to make that attack the
attack said Gorka they say Seb Gorka who
lectured the crowd about how socialism
is bad and how Democrats love to kill
babies
show me the lie
socialism is bad Democrats have embraced
socialism and Democrats have not just
embraced late term abortion they've now
embraced killing babies after they are
born not even just Ralph Northam in
Virginia Senate Democrats voted against
a bill that would offer medical
treatment to babies who were born who
survived abortions national Democrats
voted to kill babies after they are born
she attacks this as somehow bad somehow
wrong she attacks conservative sponsors
of media specifically Michael and
who's the my pillow guy who sponsors a
lot of conservative media she attacks
him for I guess for sponsoring
conservative media she attacks the RNC
and RNC chairwoman rana rena mcdaniel
she attacks Fox News host Laura Ingraham
and then she attacks John bachelor who's
a radio host who's conservative he's
been battling cancer and she attacks him
for looking ugly and old say it looks
like he's 400 years old I think after
the blowback she finally had to delete
that tweet so the the principled never
Trump stance was we're gonna conserve
conservatism how does any of that
conserve conservatism the the principled
never Trump conservatism conserved idea
was they were gonna get a ton of
interest a ton of attention by sending
this leftist reporter that worked they
did get a ton of attention but my
question now is once you've alienated
pro-lifers Reaganites Second Amendment
supporters Young Conservatives anti
socialists conservative media sponsors
Fox News and the RNC and talk radio who
is your audience
what are you conserving because the only
people who will want to read this or
those suffering from trump derangement
syndrome which is exclusively left-wing
with the exception of the dozen member
trump pers that still exists and the
left is never going to read an outlet
that calls itself conservatism conserved
just isn't going to happen they might
invite you on MSNBC to go attack the
president but that's it very misguided
and by the way after all of this after
it was clear what Molly John fast did
mr. crystal came out and tweeted quote
thanks to Molly John fast for triggering
so many snowflakes on the right with her
more don't yes yes gasp heterodox
dispatches from CPAC 2019 he's
acknowledging her attacks on pro-lifers
he's acknowledging all of that he's
celebrating it this is obviously not
conservatism concern
ironically what it actually is is
liberalism liberalized I'm not just
making a little cute play on words
that's actually the difference and this
has been a project of many people on the
right for a long time they don't want to
conserve the conservative tradition they
want to liberalize the liberal tradition
they are liberals who want to make
liberalism a bigger tempt who want
liberalism to be more liberal who want
liberalism to engage with free speech or
whatever this was the idea Bill Kristol
said a couple years ago he said he said
let's rebrand the GOP as the Liberal
Party because because we're the real
liberals and were the cool guys and when
liberalism is so great oh what a bad
idea that's a terrible idea
that's ironically Donald Trump is
actually doing the bulwarks mission
Donald Trump is actually conserving
conservatism he's saying there is an
alternative to liberalism conservatism
is not just another form of liberalism
there is a different conservative
tradition that is much more honest and
that is much more principled what the
Trump critics on the right are doing and
I think they've finally exposed that I
don't know how they could expose it in
any more obvious fashion of them to send
a leftist to go make fun of pro-lifers
at CPAC we have to get to how the left
is less principled been Donald Trump but
first let's thank our wonderful sponsor
Mike Rowe if you are looking for more
great podcasts to listen to but you're
short on time you've got to check out
the way I heard it with Mike Rowe this
podcast gives a unique take on American
history explores everything from pop
culture to politics actors to athletes
history to Hollywood and each episode is
ten minutes or less the way I heard it
is hosted by Mike Rowe he presents
stories for the curious mind with a
short attention span his storytelling is
reminiscent of the late Paul Harvey's
the rest of the story it reminds me a
lot of Ronald Reagan actually that's the
it's got a very Reagan US quality
they're all pretty short they're all
under 10 minutes it's the number one
short form podcast in America downloaded
more than 87 million times you can start
with episode 36
oh brother I don't want to ruin the
episode but it is about a sibling
rivalry siblings torn apart by politics
in a very tough American election that
was based on making America great again
and how it intersects with pop culture
how it intersects with the entertainment
industry I don't want to ruin any more
but it's a fabulous episode go to micro
comm slash podcast today and listen and
subscribe to the way I heard it mi ke ro
w e.com slash podcast micro dot-com
slash podcast you are gonna love this
especially if you're short on time it is
just such a great little dose of wit of
history of political cleverness I really
like it I'm sure you will too
check it out micro comm slash podcast
it's not just the write that has fewer
principles than Donald Trump
it's the left as well so we see this
most clearly with Alexandria o Cassio
Cortes Alexandria Ocasio Cortes our
favorite the socialist from Yorktown
Heights she said quote I'll try to do it
we're like the world is going to end in
12 years if we don't address climate
change that's what she said
so what she is saying is we need to have
zero greenhouse gases we need a full
transition off of fossil fuels within
ten years or else the world will end or
else it is not okay to have children
that's what she said you have to ask
yourself if it's moral to have children
in this world and what did we learn from
federal filings she's a hypocrite
she doesn't practice what she preaches
so alexandria cassia Cortese lives in
the city with the greatest subway system
in the world
and according to her federal filings she
listed over 1,000 uber lyft and Juneau
transactions during her campaign she
spent $30,000 on ride share guess where
her campaign headquarters was located
one minute away from the 7 train and the
7 train can take you anywhere because
the 7 train connects to a bunch of other
lines so you can get all around
she lived a 1 minute walk away from the
7 train and she spent 30 G's son rides
here apps to put that into perspective
max Rose who's another freshman Democrat
from New York he only spent $6,000 on
ride share apps and he only spent them
on 329 rides during his campaign so she
used way way multiples multiples more
than this then what happened after the
primaries after the primary AOC set her
sights outside of New York she flew
around 66 times costing $25,000 she
wants trains over planes doesn't she
well she only took 18 Amtrak rides she
flew 66 times only actually on October
12th 2018 on that day alone
AOC logged 26 car service transactions
that's in one day and what I'm pointing
out here is not that she shouldn't take
ubers not that a congresswoman shouldn't
ride what I'm pointing out is she
doesn't believe what she's saying she is
a fraud if she really thought that the
world were gonna end because of
greenhouse gases she would take the
subway which is one minute away from her
headquarters she wouldn't fly all over
the country to raise money she would
stick around town what she is saying is
do as I say not as I do
greenhouse gases for me but not for thee
it is a real hypocrisy she says this is
destroying earth imperiling the future
of the human race that's what makes it
hypocritical and she obviously doesn't
believe it because environmentalism is a
sham it is an obvious power grab now
this is to make a oh see probably not
the worst of the Democrat congressman
these days because she is not explicitly
defending killing babies after birth or
condemning the Jews I want to get to
Olano more in a second but which is what
she is doing but first I want to talk
about just the Democrat tenor here is
Ellie missed all on MSNBC using this
ridiculous tactic I know you have a
reaction Ellie I feel in my heart that
you might ever react Marc Bennett
members of Congress can't say this
because the other work with the man but
I'll have the world man Martin meadows
is so racist that he needs to be put on
display at the African American History
Museum as an artifact alright I am so
sick of Republicans thinking that the
only racist people left in America are
David Duke and Louis Farrakhan all right
white people don't get a vote my people
have been held in bondage and an
oppression in the new world for 400
years
my own counsel will I keep on who is to
be called racist all right so so when
these when these people when these white
Republicans try to tell me and bag of
and stand behind her when these people
try to tell me who is racist and who is
not racist they need to understand that
I do not care what I care about is what
their policies are and what their
actions are and Marc Meadows is a birth
sir so he can he can roll his behind out
of here
you know what he's saying what he's
saying is I don't have an argument I
don't have an argument and so I'm going
to demagogue and you can't have an
opinion you don't get a vote
you do you do you're allowed you don't
understand how opinions work mister miss
Stahl more on that in a second but first
let's make a little money with candid
have you ever had a problem with your
teeth that you've always wanted to get
fixed I have an option that can help you
won't need to go through the hassle or
long-term treatment of wire braces you
can do it all from the comfort of your
own home it's this new company called
candid candid is helping people gain
confidence through accessible and
affordable orthodontic care candids
network of highly trained orthodontists
review each and every case and directs
the entire aligner plan straighter and
brighter teeth in an average of six
months cost sixty five percent less than
braces when I was a kid I had braces you
know that doesn't look right it's really
kind of hard to pick up girls if you've
got the braces and they were very very
expensive now you can save so much money
you get clear aligners that are sent
directly to your home customized
specifically to fix and straighten your
teeth your your orthodontists will
review your specific case provide you
with a 3d preview of what your treatment
will look like candids treatment is an
average of six months and will save you
thousands compared to the other guys
you're one step away from getting
straighter whiter teeth take advantage
of candidates risk free modeling kit
guarantee plus when you use my dedicated
link candid calm
Coface e OV e fe fe you'll save 25% on
your modeling kit candid code comm slash
cough fac o VF e fe to get 25% off the
price of your modeling kit candid code
comm / co theth a so what le miss doll
just said is not true it is not true
that white people don't get to have an
opinion about something because of the
color of their skin it's not true that
black people don't get to have an
opinion about something because of the
color of their skin
that's not how opinions work thinking
people can hold opinions about anything
and they should and this is the issue
because the Democrats are no longer
thinking I'm not that's not just a
throwaway line leftism has become a
psychological twitch more than a
coherent ideology 50 years ago liberals
would say this about conservatism
conservatism is just a psychological
twitch not a philosophy that has
happened to leftism now it has happened
to leftism because of the denial of
truth because of the denial of reality
because now they they say all that
matters is the reality of oppression
ideas don't matter skin color is all
that matters this is a hysterical denier
of reality a refusal to engage with
reality you see we talked about aoc on
her environmentalism how she has no
principles she says I'm this high-minded
principled environmentalist nonsense
she's driving around gas guzzling ubers
all over the place that for that woman
to say that Donald Trump has no
principles crazy but on on the race
issue two Democrats have this problem
they're not handling their race issue
well over the the weekend
Elon omar that freshman representative
got into a spat with another Democrat
colleague Nita Lowey and she doubled
down she said quote our democracy is
built on debate congresswoman Lowey
I should not be expected to have
allegiance pledge support to a foreign
country in order to serve my country in
Congress or serve on committee the
people of the fifth elected me to serve
their interest I'm sure we agree on that
what she's saying is that Jews have a
double allegiance to
real into the u.s. it's not just a
normal criticism of a country which
would be fine to criticize is real just
like you would criticize France or Great
Britain or China or whatever that is
acceptable that's understandable
Elano Mar has a special hatred for Jews
and for Israel she she prayed in Twitter
she said I pray that Allah wakes up
people to the evils of Israel Israel has
hypnotized the world that is language
that you reserved for special contempt
that's not just the same as criticizing
some other country orther Schlesinger a
liberal historian used to say
anti-catholicism is the anti-semitism of
the left now we're finding out
anti-semitism is the anti-semitism of
the left
they are towed on this issue of race
they are totally unprincipled they can't
answer even their own colleagues who
call them out for it and what do they do
they do what le missed all did they say
you don't have an opinion you can't only
uh my opinions right because of the
color of my skin stop challenging my
opinion because I can't defend my
opinion that's what they're saying
cuz they have no argument none
whatsoever and I it even threw some
clarity for me I've never thought that
the left had principles but I I sort of
thought maybe in their own really narrow
way they're they're following a
principled position they're not they're
hypocrites on the environment they're
hypocrites on race they oh it is all
just a naked power grab a naked power
grab for socialism under the guise of
environmentalism a naked power grab for
censorship under the guise of racism or
anti racism and there you have Donald
Trump the reality TV star casino owner
real estate developer from New York a
guy that you shouldn't expect to have
principles he's the only guy with
principles among them we will get to why
CNN thinks he's Hitler in a second then
obviously we have to talk about that
Michael Jackson documentary and the
political lessons that we can learn from
a pop star molesting little kids but
first you got to go to daily wire calm
ten bucks a month $100 for annual
membership you get me you get the and
reclaim
show you get the Ben Shapiro show you
got to ask questions in the mailbag you
get the Matt Walsh show you get you get
everything you get so much and you get
this
the leftist tears tumblr ooh that's that
CPAC vintage and is that delicious CPAC
vintage two hours of unadulterated Trump
and we've only got more to come go to
daily wire we'll be right back
so CNN decides that there they're gonna
finally have to react to this CPAC
speech how are they gonna do it Donald
Trump called them out he expose them for
what they are
he exposed people in this country who
hate this country
he specifically using real examples he
has exposed his critics on the right
through his success through his
effective conservative administration so
what is the last argument that CNN can
possibly make I'll give you a hint it's
the argument that every dumb freshman
college kid makes before he learns that
the first person to invoke Adolf Hitler
in an argument loses the argument the
idea of preserving heritage taps into
historically darker times certainly not
only that though you say what we heard
from the president in that and those
remarks also could pose a national
security concern well honor his
statement makes me sick on a personal
level preserving our heritage reclaiming
our heritage that sounds a lot like a
certain leader that killed members of my
family and about six million other Jews
in the 1940s I forgot heritage is is the
Holocaust yep yep that's it if you the
were the Heritage Foundation how the
hell are they still allowed to operate
we've got the Heritage I thought they
were just a sort of mild-mannered
conservative policy wonk think-tank now
apparently their Holocaust advocates but
is that what it would be a Holocaust
proponent I don't know if you mention
heritage you think of your family
heritage your national heritage your
religious heritage you're you're
basically Hitler it's kind of funny
because there was a clip floating around
of Joe Biden saying exactly the same
thing as Trump you can find it from the
Oh a campaign said we need to preserve
our heritage and I wonder if this lady
would would say that Joe Biden is
another Hitler probably not if the left
had principles they would argue with the
points that Donald Trump is really
making if the left had principles they
would say
we don't want to preserve our national
heritage because we don't like our
national heritage because we don't like
our nation we don't like our country
that's fine that's a that's a fair
argument to make Donald Trump says I
like our country I want to preserve our
heritage the left says we hate our
country we want it to be completely
different as for Rocco Bhama said I want
to fundamentally transform the country
that's an honest argument and Obama at
his best was making an honest argument
but the left isn't doing that anymore
because they don't have any principles
because they're total hypocrites and
then and then the other thing that they
do is they they Gaslight so they they
tell you that reality as Donald Trump
observes it is not reality and that
fantasy is reality she goes on but our
national security level the president
talks about preserving our heritage as a
catch-all for implementing policies that
Miss allocate resources he pretends that
there are massive flows of legal
immigrants coming over our borders and
is spending billions of dollars on a
border wall emergency instead of paying
attention to real national security
threats he sounds a lot like despotic
leaders that have talked about white
heritage and white nationalism around
the world and is putting resources in
the wrong place and pretending that
there are foreign people trying to
influence our country in a way that just
isn't accurate he sounds a lot like
people who talk about white nationalism
didn't she cite any example she's trying
to say he's David Duke
can she cite any example of this she's
trying to say he's Hitler can she cite
any except course not
but then she goes further it's not just
the empty insults she says that there's
no such thing as a foreign invasion
Donald Trump is pretending that
foreigners are entering our country
we're apprehending almost 2,000 of them
a day we're at relative record highs of
illegal aliens pouring across our border
and then when you consider that this has
been a problem for 40 years you've 11
million 12 million illegal aliens here
then she says Donald Trump says that
those illegal aliens want to influence
our
politics yeah your party is registering
them to vote when you go to the DMV in
places like California they have a motor
voter laws they just register you to
vote when you get your driver's license
and a legal alien can get a driver's
license in many places and so they they
can be registered to vote you've seen
cases of voter fraud turn up of court
why do you think Democrats want this
flow of illegal aliens anyway because
statistically they are overwhelmingly
likely to vote for Democrats that's why
they changed their tune on it she's
telling us that reality is not so
there's nothing principled about that
and it's what this is why I think some
people get angry because I don't
criticize Donald Trump as much as they
would like me to I don't say oh he he
passed this policy this way instead of
this way oh he tweeted something that I
don't like oh he wag wag wag this is
terrible this is awful
look at the alternatives if we're
talking about the dignity of office if
we're talking about integrity if we're
talking about actually accomplishing
something in politics Who am I supposed
to prefer his disingenuous critics on
the right like at the bulwark which is
sending leftists to mock pro-lifers what
are they though dignified people how
about the people on the Left who are
race and climate hustlers who obviously
do not believe the things that they are
preaching and who are just trying to
take power the ones who say shut up if
you're white the ones who say I need to
take away your political system we need
to utterly transform the Republic and
remove your political Liberty in the
name of the some monster which I don't
even believe in Donald Trump of all the
shocking things Donald Trump seems to be
the guy in politics right now at the top
levels with the most integrity
now some people are really surprised by
this I don't know I think it maybe it's
because they got a little wrapped up
with how with anti Trump ISM and they
forget that politics is a really tough
game Pollak
attracts pretty gross people sometimes
politics rewards cynicism a lot of the
time politics is a dirty dirty business
and so President Trump comes along he
actually does what he says he's gonna do
I'll take it that's a win I don't need
to pile on disingenuously I'll criticize
him here and there like I don't think he
should go blue I don't think you should
use swear words in public it's a minor
point I hope I hope he takes my advice
but I don't think the man's presidency
should go down over a couple swear words
likewise I don't think his presidency
should go down because the FBI doesn't
like him or the DOJ doesn't like him or
the Democrats don't like him more
because he was gonna build a hotel in
Russia three years ago or because he was
a real estate developer in New York no
way no how I I really I I hope that the
people who obsess about principles will
almost make an idol of their principles
would would look at that reality the
reality of where the principles lie
right now I think it's clear that that
Donald Trump is doing the most admirable
job maybe that's damning with faint
praise but CPAC really really opened
that for me before we go we got to talk
about Michael Jackson because this shows
you a very important lesson about
celebrity and how our politics has
gotten to where they are have the
mainstream media have been able to twist
reality in the way that they have and it
all comes down to a weird pop star who
molested kids if you haven't seen it
here's just a quick clip of the accusers
in this documentary describing what
happened to them you know he settled a
case in 1993 and then he went to trial
in 2005 and Wade you got on the stand
and you testified in his behalf and
vehemently denied that any sexual
activity had taken place yes I knew I
was lying I knew that I had to lie when
I was 11 first you know I felt I had no
other choice you know 22 what was your
22 you know it's so complicated but as a
combination of
still lots of fear wrapped up with shame
my whole life my whole career would fall
apart and then wrapped up in shame he
always made me believe that I wanted
everything that we did sexually just as
much if not more than him I expect
people not to believe there's a lot of
threats better thrown my way from what
seems like angry MJ fans it goes on and
on the the documentary itself I watched
it last night is pretty disturbing the
political point I want to draw is why
people defend Michael Jackson why they
believed that a guy who regularly slept
in the same bed as little kids could not
have molested them why the mainstream
media covered up for him why the parents
brought their kids to sleep with this
man and the answer is celebrity just
just on the main point that's being
discussed did Michael Jackson molest the
kids or not because in fairness to him a
lot of false allegations get thrown
around especially at famous people
especially at rich people we've seen a
lot of those false allegations in the
last couple years we just saw one a few
weeks ago it just Jesse small that
lobbed it a completely false accusation
of a hate crime against basically
against Donald Trump against Trump
supporters because they're they're
politically powerful right now he
thought it would benefit him we saw
those ridiculous allegations against
Brett Kavanaugh we've seen a lot of fake
allegations
however Vanity Fair lays out some
essential points in this case here's
what we know for a fact about Michael
Jackson at the age of 34 Michael Jackson
slept over in over 30 consecutive nights
in the same bed as Jordie Chandler as a
little boy ten-year-old boy at the boy's
mother's house and father's house five
boys that slept with Michael Jackson in
the same bed have accused him of sexual
abuse Michael Jackson paid the
Chandler's twenty-three
in dollars to stop talking about it
Chandler Geordi Chandler correctly
described the this is a little
disgusting the discoloring on the
underside of Michael Jackson's genitals
because Michael Jackson suffers a parent
labor suffered from vitiligo a skin
discoloration disease the kid correctly
described the discoloring on the
underside of his genitals the hallway
leading to Michael Jackson's bedroom was
wired for sound so that any footsteps
would produce a lot of dingdong noises
and there would be a warning that people
were coming Michael Jackson kept an
extensive collection of pornography and
studies of naked boys next to his bed
fingerprints of the boys that he slept
in the same bed with were found next to
his on some of the pages of those books
no one ever saw Michael Jackson sleep
with a woman the parents were given tons
of expensive gifts and the fathers of
two boys who accused Michael Jackson
were estranged from their sons and they
ended up killing themselves it's very
hard to imagine a world where Michael
Jackson did not molest children now he
was acquitted on his trial first vote
was 9 to 3 9 people said he was guilty
three people said or nine people said he
was innocent three people said he was
guilty he was eventually found not
guilty one juror publicly said later
that they had a gut feeling the Michael
Jackson molested the kids but they just
felt the prosecution didn't prove it
beyond a reasonable doubt it's very
clear the Michael Jackson molest of
those kids it's hard to imagine any
reality otherwise so what's the
political point here the political point
is the power of celebrity if you've ever
met a celebrity you'll know you can get
starstruck
I've been starstruck I live in LA I see
celebrities all the time and still
sometimes I'll get a little star-struck
you it's someone you've seen on a big
screen some somebody like Michael
Jackson biggest pop star in the whole
world
there's really nothing like it today
because social media brings our stars so
much closer to us it makes them so much
more accessible but especially back then
he was so much larger than life parents
brought their kids to sleep
in Michael Jackson's bed they let him
come over and sleep in their children's
beds celebrity is so powerful so
powerful this guy when you look at it
now for people who grew up after Michael
Jackson was a big thing at you know
after the allegations came out you just
kind of look at him as a weird creep who
obviously molested children but the
people who knew him before they can't
imagine you see videos of him holding
hands walking around with little kids
constantly celebrity is so powerful and
this is how the news media operate this
is how the left operates this is what
they bet on the guy on TV said it so it
must be true
this is what they bet on this is why I
just talked about this on Drew's show
today from 1989 to 2013 there were over
200 positive mentions of Donald Trump
and rap songs then in 2015 the year he
declares as a candidate instantly all of
the mentions turn negative because the
media have to be mobilized to serve the
left they always do and so we see these
people on I mean this is why the left
has has been able to push a basically
unpopular agenda because they have all
of the celebrity with it this is why we
say who cares what the actors think we
all do we all actually care what these
celebrities think I'm sorry to say we
might not think that we do we might
think that we don't care but it does
affect the culture it does seep down and
the left relies on this the way that
conservatives can start to break that
spell is for us to use that power of
celebrity as well for us to turn it on
them and we're already doing this I mean
this is one of the main arguments that
the principled arguments against Donald
Trump is that Donald Trump is nothing
but a celebrity he's just a game show
host he's just a tabloid store all the
principled conservatives opposed
nominating that guy celebrity matters
the last most effective Republican
president we had who was he was a
Hollywood star II was a celebrity's name
was Ronald Reagan
there's nothing principled about
intentionally losing all the time
there's nothing principled about not
reacting to political realities that's
not principled that's foolish and we saw
over the weekend the biggest celebrity
on planet earth Donald Trump go out
there and for the first time in our
lifetimes turn that celebrity for
political good with great political
skill with great political principle and
you can tell the Democrats are running
scared and they're launching a zillion
investigations maybe we'll try to get
into that tomorrow they're really so
desperate to take him down now more than
ever is the time for conservatives as a
CPAC is supposed to do to unify to come
together and to defeat the left they are
they are terrified they're terrified
because this is effective conservatives
are being effective now for the first
time in a long time we should relish
that we should celebrate that we should
lift up our principles on that great
wave and I think for for the right as of
right now the future is looking very
bright come back tomorrow and we'll get
into all the bad stuff okay in the
meantime I'm Michael nose this is the
Michael Nolt show I'll see you them
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy Moore senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jesuit all Vera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19